In our last lesson,
we learned how to identify and
clean up dirty data as we build
up our optimal analytic data set.
However, once the data is clean it
might not be properly formatted for
us to use in building models.
For instance, we might want to build a
model forecasting product sales by month
over the next six months.
If the data we have available
is daily product sales,
than we're going to need to sum
this daily data up for each month.
That's one example of formatting data.
In this lesson,
we will cover how to identify when your
data needs to be formatted differently.
And how to massage the data or
arrogate it to the form required.